From the group,
the polls for you are very high.
Uh,
you are very high in the
voting intentions of 09/06.
Uh, is the risk,
for you,
it's that it doesn't demobilize a little bit
your electorate
to honesty obliges me to answer that yes,
uh,
I have 1 fear in these European elections,
is that the French and.
And. And.
In reality, especially our Indians, eh,
especially our users,
and especially in the face of
small gift to Emmanuel Macron
bying on the next nine/06.
I think on nine/06,
I said it,
it's 1
for or against thetion of France.
And I came to tell the French,
we have the opportunity,
the National Rally that I
conduct in these elections,
to the opportunity,
according to the voting intentions you were recalling,
to score the highest score in its history.
Consequently,
if we come out on top in these European elections,
we will have 1 weight
important on the stage
French,
but also on the European scene
and mission we will be given to prepare the alternation.
We must prepare the of Macron.
And I appeal today to all French people,
go vote,
we are ready,
I am ready for you
help bring to power,
in France and in Europe,
ideas that are today
widely shared in the country.
But for that,
we need you.
And so,
uh,
I urge you to obviously go vote.